[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: This was
more than just a listening
experience.
These virtual labs take
courses from being a listening
experience with maybe
some pencil p-sets to you
know your hands are active.
So you know hands-on,
brain on, right?
And when people's brains
turn on, they remember it.
SARAH HANSEN: Ever
wonder how we go
from the building blocks
of atoms to creating things
like Amazon Cloud?
And how educators introduce the
architecture of digital systems
to future engineers?
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
So here I was,
I was riding on the
Hong Kong subway,
and some young
adult comes up to me
and says, "I took
your MITx course."
And I'm sort of going, wow.
I mean, this is--
SARAH HANSEN: It's incredible.
Welcome to Chalk
Radio, a podcast about
inspired teaching at MIT.
I'm your host, Sarah Hansen,
from MIT OpenCourseWare.
Today in the
podcast, we're diving
into the world of 6.004
Computation Structures.
This is an MIT course designed
to teach undergraduate students
how digital systems
are engineered.
Some students come to the
class with prior experience
in programming and some
understanding of how computers
are structured, but others
come knowing little more
than how to use a browser.
Through the iterative
teaching practices
of a team of
instructors, this course
manages to engage
all of these students
in learning this cutting
edge information.
Today I'm speaking with
one of the key educators
in this course, Senior Lecturer
Emeritus Christopher Terman.
We'll run through what it
takes to connect and educate
an audience whose experience
might vary from complete novice
to virtual professional.
In our conversation,
Terman shares his insights
on the evolution of this
course over the last 20 years
and how its current design
is so effective at engaging
its broad student base.
We'll start off with Terman's
own story of getting engaged
with computation structures.
So how did you become interested
in computation structures?
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
Well, in the early '70s,
I was a college student trying
to earn my way through college.
And so I was the computer
operator on the third shift
for the campus computer.
That was in the era in which
you could only afford one.
And since watching the
blinking lights was boring,
I pulled out the
schematics for the computer
I was running for
the university,
and I started trying to figure
out how the computer worked.
Ever since then, it's been
sort of a lifelong interest
in figuring out how do
they actually put together
these components to
make a machine that
can do computation.
SARAH HANSEN: What kind
of background experiences
do the students bring
related to computational--
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
It's all over the map.
So some of them will come
having programmed computers
for a long time, and maybe
even know a little bit
about how the computers are
structured on the insides.
Other people have
not done beans,
and so they come with interest,
but no background at all.
SARAH HANSEN: So how do
you structure a course
to meet the needs of people with
diverse backgrounds like that?
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
Right, so to handle
really diverse
backgrounds, you have
to have a huge
range of material.
So you need something
that somebody who's just,
"I need to start
at the beginning,"
you need a beginning
for them to start at.
And for somebody who's
sort of past the first half
of your material, you
need a second half which
will engage their interest.
So I create a huge--
I think of it as a buffet.
There's lots of
dishes, and you can
start at the beginning
of the buffet
and sort of pick
it up from scratch,
or you can say, let's skip
the first couple courses
and I'm ready to dive
in sort of in the middle
of the conversation somewhere.
So I think the real key
is having a huge selection
of materials to draw from.
And that's, I think, one
of the hallmarks of 6.004
has been that we have
every possible way
of learning the material.
So not only for
different backgrounds,
but for different
learning styles.
There's sort of an
emerging best practice
about how to explain material
to people for the first time.
So you know, you want to do
a short bites, sound bites,
video bites, those
short segments
of learning where you
introduce a single skill
or a single concept.
And then you take a moment
to actually give them
some check yourself questions.
So the idea is, well, in theory
you just listened to this
or watched it, I'm going to
ask you some simple questions.
Not puzzlers,
they're just if you
understood what I just
told you on the video,
then you can answer them.
And I think the
students appreciate it.
Everything is more bite-sized.
You know, we both know.
You can imagine pushing "play"
on a 50-minute video and long
about minute--
well, I'm going to say 37,
but long about minute 6,
you're going to be, maybe
I should check my email
while I'm listening to this.
So it's, you know, keeping
things short and sweet.
Plus, it's asynchronous.
In other words, they get to
choose their time and place.
SARAH HANSEN: This must be just
such an exciting time for you
as someone who's really
interested in the scholarship
of teaching and
learning, and then
the emergence of
these digital tools
to enable that learning
through best practices.
I can feel your enthusiasm for
kind of the era that we're in.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: Yeah.
Well, you know, those of us who
teach at the university level,
we get handed a piece of
chalk and be told to teach.
Unlike the teachers for your
kids in elementary school,
who've actually gone through
a program that teaches them
how to teach, we're
just said, here, teach.
And so it's all anecdotal.
It's all trying to remember
how people taught you.
Finally, we have, you
know, the online courses
are providing a real
educational laboratory.
We're able to try out
different techniques,
we're able to make fairly
accurate assessments,
how well did that
just work, whether it
was an exercise or a video
segment or a design problem.
And so we can actually do
A/B tests in the same cadre.
So you know, it's pretty
neat having a lab.
I mean, as a scientist
and engineer,
you can build a
hypothesis, test it
through a bunch of experiments.
We can really do the experiments
with the MITx platform.
And so that's been great.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: Let's talk about
learning in the classroom
and teaching large
lecture classes.
What strategies do you have
for keeping students engaged?
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
Well, that's interesting.
Because we have so many
different materials,
really, the only students
who come to lecture
are the ones who are-- for
whom lecture is how they learn.
I was such a student.
SARAH HANSEN: I see.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
So the people
who are there are
not a draft army.
They're all volunteers.
SARAH HANSEN:
Self-selected, right?
[LAUGHTER]
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: So they're
prepared to be somewhat engaged
by a vocal presentation.
So I have a well-developed
set of materials
that I present in class that
have sort of been debugged
for having not too
much or too little,
a progression that
most people can follow.
It's a very relaxed
sort of experience,
you know, I tell jokes, I
tell stories from my career.
And it's interesting
to me how, you
know, when the students
are making comments
at the end of the semester in
the evaluations, many of them
say, I really liked the stories.
So it's, you know, after boring
you with technical details,
it's fun to say, and then when
I tried to use that, you know,
this following thing happened.
And all of a sudden, they're
sort of perking up saying, oh.
You know.
SARAH HANSEN: And I think
it helps them remember
the related content too.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: It does.
When you think about what
you remember from lectures,
it's almost never
a technical nugget.
It's a joke they told or
an accident that happened
or a mistake that was made.
And so it's-- there's this
concept called fluency,
which is basically how
smoothly things are going
and everyone's nodding, but
your mind is starting to drift
because it's all-- so it's
actually good to try to put
a little disfluency into your
lecture to actually have a, you
know, you stop and you tell a
joke, or you make a mistake,
or you drop the
chalk and say, darn,
and you look at the floor.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: Or-- and
here's what I like to do,
is you walk out from behind
the lecture table or lecturn,
and you approach the audience.
And you can see them sort
of like, wait, he's escaped.
[LAUGHTER]
And so just anything that
sort of switches up, you know,
the sort of I'm just going
along with the flow here.
So you know, making
little flows that
have things that change
make a lot of difference
in keeping people engaged.
SARAH HANSEN: I was curious
about the teaching team
behind a course like this.
So I asked Chris to
tell me a little bit
about the team of people that
make a course like this work.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
We have a little cadre
of people who are instructors.
I've been part of that
cadre every semester
for a very long time.
But we have other people who
come in from the outside.
In recent years the department
has added lecturer resources,
so there's another lecturer
associated with it,
and then faculty come in.
And then, you know, they
provide a little depth
to the gene pool.
SARAH HANSEN: Sure.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: But
then we have graduate TAs
who teach recitations.
And we have student
undergraduate TAs and then
lab assistants.
So we have this whole hierarchy.
They've all taken the course.
They've all loved it.
So sort of like me,
there's an enthusiasm
that sort of bubbles out.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
It's contagious.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: Yeah.
And the students actually-- you
know, I listed things sort of--
well, I was going
to say top down.
I'm not sure if
lecturers are at the top
or instructors are at the top.
But the students actually
prefer the other thing,
which is actually asking an
LA is not very intimidating,
to the students.
Maybe they just took
it last semester,
and so they have
fresh in their minds
what it is they needed to
do in order to get whatever
it is they're trying to get.
And then you sort of
work up the hierarchy
to get an answer
of people below.
And that way, you're
only asking questions
of the more
intimidating people when
you're pretty sure that no
one else has the answers.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
What's the role
of the online fora
in the course for
helping students feel
comfortable asking questions?
And how do you monitor it?
How do you run it productively?
This is something that educators
sometimes struggle with.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: To me,
it's a wonderful asset.
For the first time, I'm able
to make a thoughtful answer
to a question and have 180
people look at the answer,
instead of one.
And then the next person
has the same question.
You say, well, I just
spent 10 minutes, you know?
With a large class, you
can't spend 10 minutes
for each of 300 people.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: So it's a
great place to ask questions.
And so many of the
questions are, look,
I've read the material, and
I'm still not getting it.
I need an example.
I try to make students feel
very comfortable asking.
There's no cost.
They can ask
anonymously, so that
removes some of the barrier.
I think, Fall 2017, we had
about 2,500 contributions
to the forum.
SARAH HANSEN: Wow.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: The
average response time
is about 20 minutes.
And so a lot of us who are
involved in the course,
we put the notification,
postings on real time.
And so we get an
email right away.
And I think the fast
response time really
reduces the frustration
level of the students.
There's nothing like being
stuck on something and saying,
I wish I could ask somebody.
Well, for the first time we
can say, wait, I can ask,
and I can get an answer.
And the students really,
really appreciate that.
So the forum has
really, I think,
changed students'
level of frustration
when they get stuck.
Being stuck is just a 10-minute
process, not a two-day process.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's talk for a
minute about the lab
experiences in the course.
So students get
hands-on experience
doing digital design.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: Yes.
SARAH HANSEN: Could
you talk about a few
of those experiences?
And also, does that take place
here where we are right now?
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: Well,
you can do it anywhere.
It's browser-based, so there's
no software to download.
It's just on the web, you go.
SARAH HANSEN: I see.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: 20 years
ago, I gave you software
to download on your
computer to do this stuff.
[LAUGHS] You know,
landmine that was.
Everybody's environment
was a little different.
"Oh, you don't have the latest
version of that library?
Well, you can't run this.
But if you update your
library, you can't run that."
And it was really a nightmare.
So packaging up these
lab experiences in a way
that they can be used by
people around the world.
So here I was.
I was riding on the
Hong Kong subway.
And some young
adult comes up to me
and says, "I took
your MITx course,
and I really loved
doing the circuit stuff.
And I didn't have to
download anything."
And I'm sort of going, wow.
I mean, this is-- you know?
SARAH HANSEN: It's incredible.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
It's interesting to be
stopped by people.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
And they start
talking about how this was
more than just a listening
experience.
So these virtual
labs actually take
courses from being a listening
experience with maybe
some pencil p-sets to
your hands are active.
So hands-on, brain on, right?
And once people's
brains turn on,
it's amazing what they--
you know, they remember it.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
One of the distinguishing
and most interesting parts
of this course is that the
learning is greatly enhanced
by deductive reasoning.
In fact, the ability to
apply prior knowledge
to solve a problem
in front of you
is one of the main
skills students come away
with from this class.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
A lot of students
aren't very good at taking
the information they do know
and using it to deduce
the next thing to try,
or the next thing to
test, and narrow down
where the problem is.
So it's something you
have to learn how to do,
is to be organized about taking
something that isn't working,
or a complicated thing--
so parts of it are working,
but something isn't--
and trying to work
back from both
ends to somewhere in the
middle that doesn't work.
And so that's a skill that you
have to practice for a while.
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: And so we
try to help with that skill.
It's sort of neat to watch them
make the transition from coming
in as answer-focused to leaving,
like, OK, you can ask me
anything, because
I actually know
how to do things from scratch.
I can not only recognize the
right answer when I see it,
I can actually
make right answers.
SARAH HANSEN: Right
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
People feel empowered
when they can do that.
SARAH HANSEN: We'll close out
this episode with a moment
from the interview that really
struck me, because it captured
how Chris strives to
humanize the learning
experience in 6.004, how he
understands that students
are whole people who bring their
lives into classroom spaces.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN:
Doctors have this saying,
"Treat the patient,
not just the disease."
And so when students are
struggling with material,
I find it's often
the case that there's
issues that are not just what's
the technical concept or skill
that we're talking about.
And so I've learned over
the years to make myself,
as best I can,
accessible to students
who need to talk about their
life as a student, their life
as a person here at MIT.
And everybody comes with a
bit of imposter syndrome,
so you need to help students
deal with that a little bit.
So there's a lot of
issues that aren't
on the syllabus in 6.004 that
affect how they do in 6.004.
And I've learned
that it's good for me
to invest my time in helping
them think about, talk
through their larger issues.
I'm not very good at
writing prescriptions,
but you can listen.
And you can try to offer
a bit of perspective.
I think what's interesting
is that, over time, you
begin to appreciate,
if you're going
to put effort into
something, it might as well
be the best you can do.
It doesn't cost you
any more to do better.
And it's sort of
interesting to me
how many people say, oh,
they'll give that lecture,
but I won't really care.
And so you go, no, no, that's
not the right approach.
You should actually
say, look, if I'm
going to spend 40% of my
time each semester teaching
students, wouldn't it
make sense to figure out
how best to do it?
SARAH HANSEN: Right.
CHRISTOPHER TERMAN: So I
think everybody comes to that.
The more you're here
teaching, the more
you realize that you
might as well teach well.
Why the hell not?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: If you're
interested in learning more
about computation
structures, you
can find the course materials
on our website at ocw.mit.edu.
And if you're an educator,
check out our educator portal
at ocw.mit.edu/educator.
Thank you so much,
for listening.
If you enjoyed this
podcast, please
consider subscribing
and rating our show.
Until next time, I'm Sarah
Hansen from MIT OpenCourseWare.
[MUSIC PLAYING]